hello everyone and welcome back to
verses
megan are you okay
oh i'm mark ellis and usually on this
program we don't get swept up in romance
and love and all that mushy stuff it's
my philosophy that it's better to be a
guest at a wedding than a participant
never the bride always the bridesmaid
which is why today it's going to be a
heartfelt hilarious hootenanny honoring
a couple of stars from the movie
bridesmaids who also happen to be two of
the funniest and financially fortunate
performers on earth or really any other
planet including mars or wherever paul
was from yeah we got a small stage to
silver screen showdown because it's
kristen wiig taking on melissa mccarthy
right now on verses
[Music]
[Music]
it's on in one corner you have wick
gracias
para vivar and la casa
in la escuelas
and
she's a legend on saturday night live
and has made her mark in films like
ghostbusters and franchises like
despicable me in the other corner it's
fellow ghostbuster mccarthy you seem
crazy to me whose comedy chops and
propensity for ass kickery can be
witnessed in movies like spy the heat
and identity thief both actresses can
seamlessly transition from yucks to
tears to action to suspense and they're
equally comfortable carrying a movie
themselves or just popping in for a
memorable cameo although i'm told both
of them were too busy to swing by our
studio to say hello when y'all showed up
could have guaranteed you a win yes i
can be bought as it stands no one is
paying me as of the moment and i don't
get my daily peanuts unless i say my
trademark line here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three iconic rolls round
four champagne supernova and then we'll
do a wild card round that our beloved
researcher mark hoffmeyer hopes will
involve jet skis i know i know it sounds
weird but that guy lives for seadoos on
the big screen barbin star go to vista
del mar features a memorable scene
involving said aquatic vehicle but tammy
also has a quick adventure on the high
seas i always wanted to live by the
beach and own a jet ski rental house as
for mccarthy and wig they dreamed a
little bigger both began their
performing career here in l.a not this
studio exactly but on the stages of the
famed groundlings comedy troupe since
then they've conquered television movies
and exclaimed live from new york it's
saturday night too many times to count
although i'm sure mark hoffmeyer would
have counted every time they did that
had it occurred on a jet ski maybe
someday for now it's good old ghost
ghostbusting and it's going to be a
grind to see who wins and who loses
until bridesmaids 2 comes out and we
have to do this whole thing over it's
not too late hollywood get us that
sequel in the meantime let's get it on
round one box office a quick jog through
the history of tinseltown a-listers
might elicit names like cruz ford
schwarzenegger they're all great but
like a lot of other folks in that luxury
suite they're dudes enter kristen wiig
and melissa mccarthy two female stars
whose box office receipts certainly can
play with the boys it's a song from top
gun which uh has all dude fighter pilots
but if you could imagine a movie with
either wig or mccarthy flying f-18s why
not have both of them starring it
together after all some of the biggest
comedies in history have boasted both of
these ladies in the cast bridesmaids
soared into the stratosphere in 2011 and
became a massive hit thanks to a
worldwide 289 million dollar take the
two would team up again for ghostbusters
which would pull in 229 million bucks on
their own yeah they're still making bank
mccarthy projects like the heat and spy
each did over 200 million dollars and
identity thief would add another
175 million meanwhile wig was a strong
presence in wonder woman 1984 which
would take in 166 million dollars on the
big screen and the martian which
potatoed its way to 655 million dollars
which i'm told is now all invested in
cryptocurrency wig has also led her
vocal talents to animated juggernauts
like the how to train your dragon and
despicable me properties in fact seven
of her top 10 highest grossing flicks
are of the drawn on computer variety
including despicable me 3 which ranked
in over a billion dollars which will buy
a lot of overalls for those adorable
minions it also inflates kristen wiig's
per movie average significantly she's
good for 232 million dollars per movie
and her grand total thus far in a
sterling career is almost 8 billion
wow melissa mccarthy can't compete with
that gaudy number but she still hauled
in a total of 2.1 billion dollars at the
multiplex making for a per film average
of 124 million dollars so it seems like
a no-brainer that kristen wiig is going
to win this round right well remember
seven out of her top 10 biggest buck
generators were animated movies two of
those live action films on that list are
one she starred in alongside melissa
ghostbusters and bridesmaids it's easy
to see that mccarthy has been the star
in the bulk of her biggest flicks
although three out of her top ten movies
are more side rolls or cameos including
a fall down funny knee slapping
hilarious turn in this is 40. it's
impressive that she's been the star on
the poster for hits like tammy and the
boss but while wig has enjoyed rousing
success as part of an animated ensemble
she's also proven her star power in
smashes like the secret life of walter
mitty and like her pal melissa she can
steal a scene as evidenced by playing
brick tamlin's love interest in
anchorman 2. last night
a bird chased me
and i wished it was you the disparity
between kristen wiig and melissa
mccarthy's talent or star power isn't
nearly as wide as the chasm between
their box office report cards but eight
billion dollars that's a ton of money
and that 232 million dollar average draw
it's just too much to ignore it's closer
than the scoreboard would indicate but
i'm giving cheetah the win in round one
mostly for film rolls that we're not
that but hey a w is a w it's snl cast
member one snl guest host zero you're
gonna get up and we're gonna settle this
outside round two tomato meter slash
audience score and now story time with
uncle mark i had the privilege of seeing
bridesmaids at an advanced screening
packed with critics and general
audiences i obviously knew who kristen
wiig was and i think i'd heard the name
melissa mccarthy but i simply was not
aware of the comedic forces that awaited
me and the film resulted in some of the
hardest laughs i've ever had and some of
the loudest guffaws i've ever heard in a
movie theater so now we enter the round
that asks the question who was making
all those chortles was it the critics on
the tomato meter or the folks verified
on the audience score or both and while
we're at it how about every other movie
that wig or mccarthy's done yeah we get
really nosy and investigative in this
round so let's dive in melissa mccarthy
who boasts the highest tomato meter
rating for either star in the realm of
action flicks strikes first can you ever
forgive me is at a sterling 98 percent
that's outfined only by kristen wiig's
animated feature how to train your
dragon which is at 99
the other two httyds are also in the 90s
as is diary of a teenage girl and her
for which wig voices the character sexy
kitten as for movies where you see
kristen wiig the martian ranks as her
best at 91 percent and then there's
bridesmaids earning a 90 for both wig
and mccarthy and answering one of those
questions posed at the top of this round
it was both critics and audiences
giggling you seen bridesmaids it's
really funny mccarthy's also super fresh
with spy which lands at 95
however from there we dropped down into
the 70 range where movies like st
vincent at 77 percent why ghostbusters
is there at 74 and the heat is also
fresh at 66 percent but then her
starring roles slip into the rotten zone
tammy is it just 24
the boss is 22 percent and identity
thief landed with a thud at 19
it's really a good thing she stole jason
bateman's character's identity and nat
and not marty birds from ozark because
that dude never gets to nap and i
wouldn't want to get on the wrong side
of him wigs still has plenty of
freshness in the stockroom as more
dramatic turns like adventureland at 89
and the skeleton twins at 85 percent
help her solidify an overall fresh per
movie average at 65
and for all you jet ski scene
enthusiasts out there and i know there's
at least one of you barb and star is
rosy smelling at 80 percent while the
animated movie certainly helped heighten
wig's tomato meter score kristin also
has plenty of live action performances
in quality movies as well for the
audience score she's just shy of fresh
with an overall per film average of 57
percent and thanks to movie like spy at
78
mccarthy is very competitive in the
audience score division notching a 54
per movie average however her overall
tomato meter per film score just 43
what's the lesson here i don't know toss
in a few despicable me movies maybe
pepper and a cute animated dragon tail
once in a while but as kristen way can
attest not every animated feature gets
to fresh fill her movie ice age dawn of
the dinosaurs is frozen in stinkiness at
46 but i still love the squirrel what's
his name scrat scratch something like
that and you'd think live action puppets
with filthy mouse would be a recipe for
a 100 perfect tomato meter score but
happy time murders missed the mark and
only climbed to 23
i had fun with it it's not as consistent
as you want but man are there a few gut
busters in there my affinity for naked
puppets doing drugs aside wig's
filmography is just too strong in this
round her tomato meter average is fresh
and the audience score keeps the pace
well enough to earn another w over
melissa mccarthy and just like that it's
a two-nothing lead for sexy kitten which
again if you just joined us is her
character from her i don't write that
stuff i just watch it observe and report
round three iconic roles
the remarkable ability possessed by both
of these women is twofold they're
instantly recognizable as themselves
when they want to be and it usually
results in knee slapping laughter but
they're also able to wholly disappear
into someone else's shoes and make us
forget we're watching someone act like
all great performers they become the
character they're playing and they take
the audience along for the ride that's
an important trait to have if you want
to make it on the small screen or the
silver screen and it's particularly
convenient to have in this round because
it's all about who's had the better crop
of rolls thus far in their career when
it comes to rolls and kristen wiig
before we even get to the big screen
gems like a bridesmaids or skeleton
twins it's imperative that we give her
her due flowers for all those years
served on saturday night live target
lady penelope and cracker barrels across
the south we're delighted to hear the
news that famed country duo jackie and
clancy recently reunited but sometimes
an snl character is so iconic they end
up with their own movie and let's be
honest wouldn't mcgruber be anywhere
without vicky saint elmo that movie is
just so stupidly ridiculously dumb
insane funny and vicky adds so much to
the team especially because the rest of
the squad got into that van a little too
quick the greatness of wig is that she
can have an impact in a film without
having her name above the movie's title
supporting roles like jill and knocked
up her johnny and anchorman 2 prove her
ability to steal a scene in a variety of
ways and she made a formidable foe for
wonder woman way back when purple ran
was at the top of the charts and she was
cheetah sometimes comic book movie
villains especially in sequels can feel
a little one note and while i have no
love loss for wonder woman 1984 i can
say that wig's performance as a clumsy
shy museum curator-turned-arch-nemesis
felt very three-dimensional and we could
understand her point of view pov has
never really been an issue for melissa
mccarthy characters we usually know
where she stands relatively quickly
whether it's the hardwired badass from
the heat or the thrilled to be on the
team trainee from spy every time she's
on screen we instantly get where she's
coming from mccarthy can pull off
physical comedy so well from a
ghostbuster to a bridesmaid and her and
wig are the perfect compliment for one
another in those movies melissa
mccarthy's megan in bridesmaids has the
rare ability to take a great ensemble
cast and put the movie on her back and
steal scenes without feeling like she's
taking away anyone else's moment more
recently wig is branched out into more
dramatic roles like the skeleton twins
but she'll always be welcome in the
world of absurd comedy like barb and
star go to vista del mar besides being a
tremendous title it's just flat out
funny the entire trip her most standout
roles to me seem to be the supporting
ones like his paulette in adventureland
or ruth in the stoner alien comedy paul
which now is my official new favorite
genre of film it's not to say we can't
carry a scene a sketch or an entire
movie but so far her biggest wins have
come as part of a tremendous squad
mccarthy is certainly able to team up as
evidenced by her box office hits with
her pal kristen but even more frequently
she can be seen as the star of the film
like literally as the boss which by the
way allows her to wear the turtlenecks
the turtlenecks do not wear her
oh my gosh
roles like tammy or even her human cop
in a world of puppets in happy time
murders have solidified mccarthy as an
a-list lead player but it doesn't mean
she can't play on a great team her and
sandra bullock are perfect together in
the heat and her back and forth with
jason bateman an identity thief is worth
the price of admission but is mccarthy's
portrayal of real-life criminal lee
israel and can you ever forgive me that
elevated her to another plateau this
woman forged tons of documents thought
to be precious collector's items but we
still can't help but root for her not to
succeed because i know that's wrong and
it's a sin i don't i want her to get
some help or see the error of her ways
or just hang out with richard e grant
more it's a heartbreaking performance
that also gives us tons of levity laughs
and yeah i cried i got some tears out of
that movie what seals the deal for
mccarthy in this round is her ability to
show up for a scene and still be the
most memorable part of the film just
enjoy the end credits of this is 40 and
you can thank me later i would like to
rear up and jackknife my legs and kick
you both in the jaw with my foot bone
that's what i would love
i wish my
foot would go right through your skull
and while kristen wait obviously has the
more prominent sketch show resume
melissa mccarthy she can play in that
ballpark as well witness her poppins to
snl as white house press secretary sean
spicer now i'd like to
begin today by apologizing on behalf of
you to me
for how you have treated me these last
two weeks
and that apology is not accepted
and i rest my case melissa mccarthy is
finally on the board in this ball game
and we got us a two to one barn burner
round four champagne supernova
sure i could have just named this round
awards but this is way more fun you know
folks sip champagne at award shows and
they frequently feature a galaxy of
stars so i stand by my creative license
thanks gallagher brothers but i'll begin
the awards show round by mentioning that
one annual affair that most stars look
forward to is the razzies why well
because sometimes i actually think
getting a razzy nomination can be a good
thing it means you took a risk now maybe
that risk didn't pay off for the movie
in which you broaden your horizon wasn't
all that good but still bravo that's the
case with wonder woman 1984. the movie
was
look i thought wig was good as cheetah
yet she was nominated for a razzy but
again i applaud the achievement that's
the second razzie nomination in wig's
career and she capitalized on her first
with the win for the worst supporting
actress for zoolander 2. does anybody
think that there's a more horrendous
sequel and does anybody think that
zoolander 2 is kristen wiig's fault of
course not but wow what a just
yikes like bad sequels i can live with
but somehow this one ruined the first
zoolander for me however none of that
was wigg's fault melissa mccarthy has
been honored or shamed at the razzies as
well that has
to count for something she was nominated
for tammy and won for a combo of roles
in happy time murders and life of the
party well i would
i would accept that with an open mouth
but and there's always a butt she also
won the redeemer award for playing lee
israel and can you ever forgive me
i'm not sure if we'll forgive the
razzies for trashing that funny muppet
gangster flick but for someone to be so
good in a film that even the razzies has
to acknowledge it color me impressed
well it's the first time i've heard you
say that all right enough with the mean
awards let's shift gears into the most
prestigious prize of the cinema calendar
that's not named the golden tomatoes
oscar neither leading lady has won the
tiny c-3po yet but they both have shown
plenty of potential with their
nominations whig shared a best original
screenplay nod with the great annie
mamolo for bridesmaids and it was also
that wilson phillips wedding movie that
saw mccarthy earn a nomination for best
supporting actress she would then go on
to attend the ceremony as a best lead
actress nominee for the flick that even
the razzies couldn't get enough of can
you ever forgive me can we ever forgive
oscar for not giving mccarthy the win
that year
all right well olivia coleman won for
the favorite and she's great but i still
would have gone with glenn close and the
wife have you all seen that movie oh
she's so good and now i'm off topic if
we pivot from the academy awards to the
emmys one might think that it's gonna be
advantage wig and why not she earned an
emmy nomination six years in a row as a
player on saturday night live which if
that's not a record that's got to be
close however mccarthy knows a thing or
two about this annual event as well from
2011 to 2017 she earned six nominations
and walked away with two wins in 2011
she took home the prize for outstanding
lead actress in a comedy series for the
sitcom mike and molly and in 2017 she
won for outstanding guest actress for
her participation in drum roll please
live from new york it's saturday night
you probably already guessed and now my
two cents i enjoy the award shows i
might even get to host a few before it's
all said and done still waiting for that
call golden tomatoes but they aren't the
be-all end-all of whether a movie or a
performance is worthy of our affection
and that's especially true if you
consider the history of how the comedy
genre has fared at these fancy galas you
really think it's easier to make someone
belly laugh than it is to make him cry
all it takes for me to ball is disney
killing off a parent in the first three
minutes of every one of their movies
comedy is one of the hardest tricks to
pull off and these two ladies have had
us in stitches for almost two decades at
peace now but don't worry those chuckles
will be rewarded in the next round for
now melissa mccarthy gets the win for
being able to break through those
anti-laugh awards show barriers both
kristen and melissa could have multiple
emmys and oscars on their shelves before
it's all said and done but right now
it's a w for mccarthy and we got us a
tied ball game two to two oh no that's
the opposite of what i thought you were
gonna say and now it's time for the wild
card round hoots and hollers that's one
of the ways that we say laughter in the
south turtles belly laughs yuck yucks
you call them what you will these two
incredibly versatile performers started
out their career with basically the same
goal make the audience laugh as much and
as hard as humanly possible or in
kristen wick's case occasionally as hard
as a food item can ha ha like she did
for sausage party it sounds weird to say
but she was fantastic in her role as a
hot dog bun if laughter is the best
medicine then these two greats are phds
they're critical and box office success
our testament to the claim that i'm not
the only one who's been howling with
delight ever since i first met them in a
virtual sense wig arrived on my radar
first when she debuted on snl in 2005.
and to be honest i've only been a casual
viewer of snl since i was in college and
comedy central whatever the reruns of
the late 80s early 90s years but once i
saw target lady for the first time i had
a new contender for my all-time snl
dream ensemble what i love most about
kristen wiig on that show is how
uncomfortable and awkward her characters
can be but she never makes the audience
feel that tension it's likely because we
trust her as such a genius performer
that we know that there's laughs on the
way so enjoy the ride this ought to be
fun yeah i hear that
i can probably hear you better just
because i really get errors
i was in a listening contest this
morning i came in first in seconds oh i
just have really big eardrums probably
bigger than yours she could sing and
dance and completely reinvent herself
multiple times within that 90-minute
window and that versatility is something
that precious few snl cast members have
ever been able to pull off dan aykroyd
phil hartman eddie murphy maybe will
ferrell would be on that list and wig is
right at the top with those fellas her
ability to take an awkward moment and
squeeze all the comedic juice out of it
may have been honed on tv but it paid
off on the big screen too in the form of
judgy executive jill from knocked up it
just grosses me out
when i know that people are pregnant
because i think about the birth
everything's so wet her consistent
passive aggressiveness towards katherine
heigl's character is the source of some
of the biggest laughs in the whole film
but if it's mark falling on the floor
concerned for his own well-being because
he's so out of breath from laughing that
hard i have to remind everyone of the
brilliance of the lovemaking scenes in
mcgruber they're so painfully funny
spoofing every ridiculous action movie
sex scene and standing on its own merit
at the same time and apparently the bulk
of those scenes were shot on kristen
wiig's birthday
it's a present that we all got to open
melissa mccarthy may not have made my
admittedly weak radar until bridesmaids
but is there anything better than when a
new comedic force enters your airspace
with such an immediate impactful arrival
as a movie stealing performance that's
not an insult to anyone else in that
film by the way maya rudolph attempting
to cross the street might be one of the
biggest laughs i've ever heard in a
movie house but there is something about
melissa mccarthy's always simmering
persona that was irresistible and i've
been hooked ever since
her and wig have had some great
on-screen moments like when melissa gets
possessed in ghostbusters but the first
time i knew we had a new genius on our
hands was the air marshall sequence from
bridesmaids that's a real life hubby and
frequent director ben falcone who she's
convinced as an undercover agent on the
plane
hey not air marshall john you want to
get back in that restroom and not rest
no i have to get back to my seat yeah
you got to get back on my seat
you get it it never gets old melissa
mccarthy's physical comedy is one of the
best tools on her utility belt for spy
she did combat training for two months
and the moves paid off as they did her
rough and tumble cop character in the
heat moments like spy's kitchen fight
accentuate her brilliance with movement
and it's the perfect pair to the quick
abrasive way with words that most of her
characters harbor it doesn't matter if
she's physically tussling with a puppet
or verbally sparring in a flick like the
boss the end result is always a rousing
round of laughter a combination like
mccarthy and wig is nearly unbeatable in
terms of comedic value and the best
illustration of their many talents is
the pity party scene from bridesmaids
mccarthy's megan and wake's annie are
engaging with their best individual
traits annie battling herself doubt and
megan's overbearing confidence unite for
a scene that has big laughs and heart
all at once yeah i think annie wants a
little pity parties
my god what are you doing i'm life huh
life bothering you oh i'm lying
that it feels so natural between those
two belies the fact that this so rarely
happens in a raunchy comedy as much as i
admire kristen wiig's comedic chops and
versatility i could probably count on
one hand how many people have made me
laugh as hard in my entire life as
melissa mccarthy you hope to get a town
like hers once in a generation where she
can kill you with an overwhelming
hurricane of physical stunt work or just
with a look she's been the standout in
tremendous ensembles a revered lead on
her own and oh by the way she can also
play on the dramatic side of the aisle
with just about anyone and for my
closing argument i'll once again refer
you to the outtakes from this is 40. i
barely remember the movie other than
paul rudd gets in a bike fight and
there's a funny van halen line i'm sure
i enjoyed it but seeing how tough it is
for great actors like rudd and leslie
mann to keep a straight face against
mccarthy shows that she's just on
another level and for that melissa
mccarthy gets a comeback victory against
a very worthy opponent in kristen wiig
down goes cheetah she'll be fine
mccarthy wins the round and thus the
match i'm gonna go take a nap i'm tired
i think it's a good idea get you on the
flip side [ __ ]
this has been one of my favorite
episodes of versus to do because i got
to revisit so many of the great comedic
performances on a screen of any size
over the last 15 years and the beauty of
humor is that everyone's sensibility is
different i have mine you have yours and
the oscars apparently doesn't have one
at all did they get mad did they get mad
at the see look the stubborn little
fella can't even take a joke well my
opinion went to melissa mccarthy today
but i'm just one dude here now it's your
turn world who's your favorite between
these two comedic maestros hit me up on
social media at mark ellis live with
your vote and defend your answer with
all the conviction that megan had when
she was sure that guy was an undercover
air marshal thanks for watching i'm mark
ellis and remember always better to be
the bridesmaid the bride and the groom
they have to be married in the ceremony
and you just get to dance and enjoy the
open bar
cheers
[Music]
you